Russia has officially assumed the
presidency of the U.N security Council
this weekend on Saturday Russia took
over the un's top security body as part
of a regular monthly rotation the last
time Moscow held the post was in
February 2022 when its troops launched a
full-scale invasion of Ukraine on Friday
the Kremlin said it planned to quote
exercise all its rights while in the
role Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski is calling the move absurd
adding that it shows the institutions
total bankruptcy zielinski says it's
time for a general overhaul of global
institutions including the security
Council
is
[Music]
we urge Russia to conduct itself
professionally during its scheduled
presidency in April and for the council
to continue to imp to to continue it's
important work on a number of issues of
Peace security across the world
that said we expect Russia to continue
to use its seat on the council to spread
disinformation and to try to distract
from the attempt to justify its actions
in Ukraine and the war crimes members of
its forces are committing and its
outrageous violations of the U.N Charter
a country that flagrantly violates the
U.N Charter and invades its neighbor has
no place on the U.N security Council